The first thing I want to tell you guys and you need to remember this and I will write this on here
And make sure it's on the printout on the actual script
Guys this you need to realize that you you don't want this to be high pressure. Okay?
People get scared of high pressure
They hate it. They hate it. They hate it
So you do not want them to be scared of like you don't want them to as soon as they feel pressure
They're gonna they're gonna bounce they're gonna ghost you they're gonna think of a reason like they're not even gonna be paying attention
They're just going to be thinking of a reason why they can how they can get you off their screen. I'm not kidding
so
The couple calls i've been on recently what i've heard is
Guys, I definitely think it's important to let them know. Hey, please don't leave me in
I don't know zone make sure that like just give me a yes or no
but some of you guys are saying that in such a way that it's scaring people off like
There's a couple ways to say that and you don't need to say hey just just to confirm
You will give me a yes or no by the end of this, correct? Like
That's just adding pressure that doesn't need to be added in a different way of saying that it would be like
Hey, like I told you the only thing I ask is just don't leave me in. I don't know zone. That's all I ask
Okay, i've given you enough references and everything else by the end of this. This is a good fit
Let's move forward if it's not then let's not but that's my only ask. Is that fair?
Those are completely different. One of them is giving a ton of pressure. Oh shit. He's gonna like
Crap, how do I get this guy off the call? I don't want to I don't want to have to go into this high pressure situation
so guys
Take the pressure off the call
Take the pressure off of the customer because that is not going to help you that is not something that helps you get the deal
Okay, even though at the end you're going to ask for the deal and if needed we're going to apply a little pressure
We don't want the whole call them to be thinking about that close and thinking about how do I get them off the call?
so so
Take off the pressure. Okay number one and I just want you to be thinking about that the whole time
and and it's kind of like even like um, I know like with ryan even it's like it's and and and
Mahmood's been doing this on his calls like my whole sales pitch is like hey if this makes sense great
If not, no harm, no foul if not, no big deal
I'm repeating these phrases because I want this to seem like no big deal even though deep down
This is a huge deal for me